[Music]
so I'm going to show you a couple of
images of people who I think are who may
or may not be style icons and if you
think their style icons I want you to
put a thumb up and if you think they're
not I want you to thumbs down and I was
quite complicated instructions but I
think you've got it okay so let's try
yeah
style icon Cary Grant yes Cary Grant in
North by Northwest
in 1959 he's wearing a suit that is made
cut by Kilgore's French and Stanberry
the Savile route Savile Row tailors and
the suit had to be replicated eight
times for when he was shooting North by
Northwest because if you know the film
he's constantly ducking under crop
dusters and clinging from Mount Rushmore
and it was replicated by Quinta know of
Beverly Hills and in the scene in the
hotel room where he takes off his suit
you can see the label and it says Quinta
know an interesting thing about Cary
Grant for me is that his father was a
tailors cutter and he had a very fraught
relationship with his father which I
write about in my book and I will tell
you more about at some point so yes Cary
Grant style icon Oh Madonna style icon I
mean I think she's going for slightly
deranged pirate phase at the moment but
I like it very much
she's very important person to me
janelle monae yes
reinvented the tuxedo for women in and
non-binary identifying people in the
21st century she's done something
amazing for the idea of masculinity
which she's contoured by appropriating
or claiming the suits
Franson I find it very hard to look at
this picture because his knees look
there's something so distressingly
vulnerable about his pink knees but this
is a very daring ensemble of fleece and
surfer shorts a man with the courage to
mix a striped beanie hat
dashingly ask you with crumpled florals
if he can't bring about brexit who can
look you can carry this off with the
moment were talking about something
called shamble chic boris is the the
poster boy if you like of an idea of
shamble chic which i think the logic of
which is that you dressed like a walking
whoopee cushion so this is a trick quiz
of course everybody is a style icon but
I did want to narrow in on Boris Johnson
because we don't talk about him enough
but also for me he's indicative of a
certain kind of analysis about about
fashion that's happening at the moment
and the argument of my book is that we
need to take a really serious look at
what we were and many people take that
to mean something more facetious than
what I mean they mean analyzing what
politicians were and that seems to me a
very stupid and uninteresting way to
talk about clothes so you would have
heard the conversations about resume
wearing leopard spotted suede heels and
whether that compromises her feminist
ideals how boring or is Angela Merkel
appropriating masculinity or mimicking
masculinity by wearing these blocky boxy
suits is Jeremy Corbyn an inappropriate
leader because he wears a duffle coats
or
whatever that is an anorak I think to a
really important event is Melania
sending us messages through her coat all
of those analysis I think are rubbish I
think they're part of a bigger dead cat
strategy where spin doctors are throwing
things on the table to distract us from
what's really happening in the world and
you should ignore that and what I'm
going to try and talk about you see how
I coordinated the big cross with my
dress today I really go through some
consideration but I don't I would ignore
that version of fashion in politics I
want to suggest and more existential and
more emotional as well as intellectual
account of clothes I'm gonna try and
explain what that might mean
despite like I've dismissed that
political analysis of fashion I don't
want you to think that there isn't a
politics of fashion it seems to me
absolutely true that in moments of
crisis what we wear can feel like the
most trivial of concerns but it seems to
me so curious if you think about it but
so many of our most heated cultural
disputes are circular in our settling
around the right to wear particular
clothes in particular circumstances so
just think about the conversations we're
having at the moment about trans
identity a significant part of that
conversation is about the right to wear
dress or in seemingly or not not gender
specific ways or think about the veil
and the hijab brush wants of course said
that women in burkas look like
letterboxes the burqa and the hijab have
become a shorthand for Islam and we've
been in a near constant state of anxiety
for many years now about the place of
the veil in Europe or would think about
conversations about street harassment
and rape blame how often and regularly
how rude routine it is to for the
conversation to end up talking about the
length of of hems and the the clothes
that women are wearing in some of the
most vulnerable moments of their life so
what I'm trying to say here by setting
out those examples is that in clothes
some of our most serious cultural cry
are happening in fact there is even a
way in which I I think you could argue
that the most serious questions about
sex and gender and religion and violence
are happening in clothes so if anybody
ever tells you that to think about
clothes is frivolous or rain you can
rebuke them things are happening in the
way that we dress and it's timely we
attended to it more carefully and my
book tries to do that it tries to take a
philosophical approach to clothes
because our clothes have always been
there our clothes have been witness to
all the things that we do and desire and
we have never regarded them with great
seriousness so I wanted to start my
conversation with you with a question
why why have we come to think that
clothes don't matter I've got a number
of suggestions as to why that might be
first of all fashion seems deeply
antithetical to philosophy philosophy is
a discipline or body of work that wants
to be universal and fashion seems
exclusive philosophy is about lasting
truths and fashion seems to be about
fads philosophy purports to be about
what's deep inside fashion seems to be
about maiya surfaces philosophy is
concerned with the serious realm of
ideas fashion seems like the most
frivolous realm of appearances so you
can see quite how oppositional these two
realms are the American essayist pert
and philosopher Ralph Waldo Emerson
apparently this is apocryphal I've never
been able to find the quote but it
sounds like him he said that one reason
to dress well is that dogs respect it
and will not attack you in good clothes
and anybody who's ever known a dog will
know that's not true if you've got a
hairy Labrador and had muddy pawprints
all over your favorite dress or suit
then you know that's not true
dogs don't respect your clothes but
Emerson is part of a larger
philosophical tradition which expresses
skepticism about clothes and this is to
do with the problem of appearance the
idea that appearances are deceptive
now in philosophy this is a slightly
technical boring it seems to me actually
conversation appearances belong to a
really tiresome technical debate about
the limits of knowledge and the nature
of perception it is but the question of
appearance is almost always disconnected
from dress in philosophy and if you know
the discussion of plato's in Plato's
Republic of the allegory of the cave
Plato is puzzling over how we
distinguish between the appearance of
reality and reality itself
Plato ends up exhorting us to seek truth
and to be mistrustful of the simulations
of disguises of appearances that keep us
from truth after Plato we get Kant he's
also concerned with appearance and he
thinks of it as a philosophical problem
which is about the relationship between
the reality of things as they really are
and the limited ways in which we
perceive them it's a very potted history
of Plato and camp but I want to set up
this idea that the big hitters in
philosophy begin by telling us doubt
appearances but truth is naked and be
wary of disguise suspicion or the
dressing up of reality and the thing
that interests me about that is that
those long hand-wringing debates about
appearance rarely think about what it
might mean to live in the world and look
a particular way what it might mean to
work through the walk through the world
in a body that is dressed and appear to
other people to present ourselves to
other people and that's what I'm trying
to think about a version of philosophy
that doesn't pretend that being
interested in material or
phenomenological life is unimportant
it's not it's the single most important
thing of all it seems to me that we have
bored is that we stand in front of each
other but my cotton sleeve will rub
against your linen shirt later this
afternoon and that means something to me
it seems to me and it's warrants our
inspection the mother baits swaps and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at AI TV
you